i'll turn your attention to this one
part of an interview you did
on fox a couple weeks ago a few weeks
ago
i think with harrison uh harris faulkner
i want to get your reaction on this
this is you on fox news on september 9th
i believe
progressive district attorneys are
anti-police
pro-criminal and overwhelmingly elected
with george soros's money
and they're a major cause of the
violence we're seeing because they keep
putting the violent criminals back on
the street
i'm not sure we need to bring george
into this
i was going to say you'd get the last
word speaker
he paid for it i mean why can't we
discuss the fact that millions of
dollars
i agree with that george charles doesn't
need to be a part of this conversation
okay so it's verboten
all right i mean that's got to be one of
the most
uncomfortable moments of tv whether it's
fox or
and you're seeing murdoch's sons uh
recently giving
money to the democratic party so the
reason why i'm saying this is
if fox goes left and an interview like
that happens i want to get your reaction
on that period
but if fox goes left what's the only
media channel that's left for the right
to
you know give their own side of the
argument well i mean first of all
what you saw was a mistake and then
fox had no problem with talking about
soros
and in fact the next day um
she she apologized uh for
uh the way it was mishandled and what
had happened was we see harris
harris or the lady in the yellowstone
okay
the other woman is a professional
democrat and was doing her job which is
to clutter it up
and try to not let us score points
against democrats
uh harris i think because we were
separated it was all virtual
i was i think actually in rome at the
time uh and so
uh harris was a half step back uh in in
sort of sorting it out because it was
wasn't like we were on the same couch
uh the next day i did her show and she
openly apologized and said look
we would never cut you you know we love
having you on etc
so i think it was actually a technical
mistake now having said that
if at some point fox decides to become
a left-wing establishment channel uh
there will be three or four channels
uh probably starting with newsmax but
there will be three or four different
channels competing
to replace fox i i don't think the fox
audience
is going to go with fox if it becomes a
left-wing channel
nor nor by the way when i look at their
lineup
um i mean i i don't i don't think you
know that that
tucker or sean or or laura
are about to become moderates so they
did
they would have a long way to go and i
do fox and friends all the time
uh and i i feel very comfortable doing
all these shows
and generally speaking they're probably
not quite
as far to the right as they were under
ales but they're still far and away
the most effective conservative vehicle
in the country
you